he's one of the greatest shooters of all
time he's a Hall of Famer Reggie Miller
part of TNT's all-star festivities in
Chicago as well as the all-star game on
Sunday at 8:00 Eastern on TNT good
morning reg how are you
[Music]
do you have any Oscar nominees or
winners in your neighborhood we go
through this every week okay though I do
know that Brad Pitt is somewhere in the
vicinity of where I'm currently living
in Calabasas and he is a Supporting
Actor winner okay oh yes answer your
question yes I just don't know don't you
just drive around the neighborhood
sometimes just to check out houses see
who lives in LA I Drive around the
neighborhood saying to myself why
couldn't I squeezed a few more jumpers
out of this right to afford to live at
some of these estates that they are
living in yes I think you did pretty
well I did okay yeah I think I've done
better yeah I could have done better
well you look at all could you look at
these these salaries now oh right I mean
it's all I carry I curse all in care
every day you were born too early the
other way to Theodore yeah we helped
pave the way right because I'm sure the
players you know Jerry West and Oscar
Robertson and willed and the 60s and 70s
they helped pave the way for us as well
so that's how I look at things and
that's the way to look at it that's the
way to look at all right a couple things
here can the Rockets small ball win a
title title no series or two yes
depending on the matchup because I
understand what they're doing I don't
think I mean you got Russell Westbrook
who can't shoot threes and he and he has
the ball a lot unless they're just gonna
say to Russ hey just you go to the hoop
constantly offense and defense just go
to the rim and let Everett let the other
people who can shoot actually shoot here
and you know are they gonna average 50
to 60 three-pointers per game is that
the goal yes to that but that we're not
surprised about that because they led
the league in three-point attempts and
three-point makes you know the last you
know in the D'Antoni era they're in in
Houston what you saw last night
in the defense when they played Utah is
probably how teams are going to play
Houston from here on out as soon as
harden crosses the half-court line it's
a soft double will come up they're gonna
play off of Russ so when the ball is
strong to Westbrook they're gonna dare
him to shoot which he's not going to
shoot he's gonna drive and he had a
monster game with 37 or 39 points and
double-figure assists but they are
always going to make it difficult on
James Harden to score because he's gonna
have to score out of soft double teams
and triple teams and he's gonna make the
PJ Tucker's and those kind of guys Eric
gourds they're gonna make those guys
beat you from from distance and if they
make twenty threes and shoot above 45
percent and it's going to be a loss but
where you have to punish them is if
they're gonna start players six seven
six six you got to kill them on the
offensive glass and that's what Rudy
Gobert and Utah did they made timely
shots don't get me wrong
Bogdanovich hit the big three at the
buzzer to win it but I think they could
we've seen this before with Don Nelson
and Golden State in a certain series
when that gold assay team upset the
number one Dallas team if you remember
that you know you know ten plus years
ago so we've seen this this movie before
I just don't think in the long run you
can win a championship that way
how did did it come off come off to you
with the Lakers trying to get Darren
Collison to come out of retirement then
he said no that they might be interested
in junior Smith or dion Waiters
I think the Lakers are kind of just
looking for pieces they they need
outside shooting I know they needed a
backup point guard you know for Caruso
and Rishon Rondo
but Collison decided to stay retired I
could kind of see the GRS risk because
he wanted championship with LeBron and I
think he's familiar or would be familiar
in that system
you know just run to the corner and spot
up basically but he hasn't been on the
court for a while so I don't know how
useful that would be for the Lakers at
they're just trying right really to
grasp straws right here to find
complementary pieces it's not desperate
to you I mean I know like junior Smith
is not playing for a reason so there are
other desperate I mean it's also a guy
with championship experience too and he
did a lot of big shots in his career
especially with LeBron you won Jaron
Smith I'd have to see him first I want
to gr if that was on that team that won
a championship yeah but you're not
getting that one we don't know okay III
think if you're the Lakers you have
avoided drama this year
Vogel's been perfect for them you've
avoided drama and I don't need to bring
it in to do I want to bring in dion
Waiters sure about that one because he
has kind of been a locker room problem
while he was in Miami so I'm not quite
sure about that one but I would have
zero problem with JR Smith coming in a
guy that has championship experience
they can knock down threes
the question is physically is he capable
you know he's been away from basketball
for a bit but we saw this was Camello he
was away for just about a year and has
it looked too bad
so if he's kept his body in shape and
you know have that hand-eye and that
trigger arm ready who know who knows
contain Ian Lillard be the MVP this year
he could but he won't just because right
now he's just scratching to try to get
a slot in Western Conference we all know
it's altered to compose to lose okay
that's wrapped up the Onyx is won in the
MVP unless he gets I even think if he
gets injured right now he would probably
still win MVP he's that far ahead but
then I think you got to throw in LeBron
and the success of the Lakers I think
LeBron would probably be number two Luca
and his especially the first half of the
season has been fantastic but he's been
hurt lately so that's kind of hurt him
but now you put what Lillard has done
over the last month it's been phenomenal
and if they can find a way to get to
that eighth spot I think they're two and
a half or three behind Memphis for that
a spot in the Western Conference what he
has done with all the injuries in the
trades and the roster turnover in
Portland he would probably be in my top
three of MVP right now probably Yanis
LeBron and then Lillard I was looking at
Yanis and LeBron their rosters and I'm
looking at LeBrons roster
LeBron Anthony Davis looka James Harden
Kawhi Leonard that's that's a pretty
good starting five right there I will
say this LeBron has the all name roster
but I really do like your honor says
it's it's more of a team type roster I
think he kind of alluded to that he's
like I want honey you guys are gonna
pass the ball so on paper I'm sure
everyone's gonna go with LeBrons team I
am picking the honestest team to win
Sunday's all-star game okay it's more
it's constructed more as a team a guys
kind of understand their roles the
question is they got to go out and play
hard I I think he honest his team is
more constructed for that so I'm pulling
the upset and going with the honestest
team on Sunday who played who took the
all-star game as serious as a regular
game or a postseason game when you
played in it
MJ did but MJ you always took every game
serious because he felt it was a chance
to one-up the best players in the game
look I remember in 1990 my first
all-star game in Miami and but it was a
problem no reg with Michael being that
serious and that like you can answer it
now the people have no okay like you
know nobody said Mike come on he's up
let's have fun oh no no no because there
was so much trash talking back in those
days of the all-star game yeah alright
no walking into the locker room in Miami
you know I was 23 24 at the time and in
the east it was Larry it was Charles it
was MJ Isiah Joe Dumars Rodman coach
wise the Hall of Famer Chuck Daly so I
walk in and no one's saying any anything
to one another and this is like the
height of the bad boys and the rise of
Chicago so there was tension in there
I'm like oh my god what if I walked into
and uh so guys were barely speaking to
one another but as soon as the jump ball
went it was like let's kill the West
let's kill magic let's kill war it was
like I was like this is this is awesome
you know but as soon as that 48 48
minutes was over it was like they went
back to their isolated corners but they
wanted to destroy the Western we wanted
to destroy the Western Conference I'm
looking at the all-star festivities they
got the slam dunk contest and I'm not
interested in that the three-point
contest they still like it know why
because adding a 2.30 point shot and
three points to that you don't I love
that you know all right
think of the gust of all liver leads the
league with 35 plus more than 35 him
entry young yeah 35 plus three-point
shots
this season that adds a wrinkle to it
you had 10 seconds to it and now you
have to drop it sorry no I think that's
good
look the game has evolved and you've got
to you've got to add changes to it but
Ridge I would still love to see let's
say Damian Lillard picked you and you
got two racks he got three racks and you
were a team and then you went against
let's say if Steph Curry was playing and
Richland you guys get two racks so you
don't get tired and you let the young
guys get three racks if you want to do
the extra 30 footer then I'm fine with
that too but I would make it where we
bring back the old with an old school
new school
hey you would do this in a second I
would do that in a heartbeat only two
racks and I'd probably take the flu that
would be good now the question is who
would I team I could team up with anyone
would give up with Luka I would team up
with anyone okay but what racks would
you take your two best racks would be
situated where I would probably say is
your Norman Warner okay yeah the short
quarter and the wing that would probably
be my two so I'll either be the first
two and let my partner do the first
three in the long ball or I do the last
two the last wing in the last corner one
who no see isn't that more interesting
than adding two 30-footers no I still
want to see that - I'll let you have
that but I think you I they love to
celebrate the past you bring him in I
mean that that would be great if it team
you guys up now if they add this
obviously not this year of a back in
Indiana the the following year are you
gonna take credit for this because you
should I don't
great idea imagine all idea I'm a giver
I'm the John Stockton of radio I just I
just give ya that's all you can take
credit for it I have no problem with
that
I'm not taking credit for it because
it's a great idea but uh I think you can
get enough of the you can get it
pager because you can still shoot you
get Craig Hodges you can still shoot ray
myself that's four alone right there
Dell Ellis can still light it up Glen
Rice can still light it up so there is
enough to team up with the young fellas
and Dell curry can still shoot right now
price Dell and stuff yeah I'd be good I
would take them on I would like that of
course you would
yeah I don't care who you get paired
with you'll be great I don't I'm not
concerned about you I think you know I
don't want these older guys to go out
there and get hurt but that's why I'm I
only give you two two racks when the the
whole [ __ ] used to get hurt when they
made them play in the all-star game when
they have that like fantasy game and
guys were tearing APL's and Achilles and
they are like God rest his soul
Commissioner Stern was like no more no
more of a game we have we got to stop
this Aaron up body limbs are you on my
Memphis grizzly beng wagon to make the
playoffs or just just get on now get on
early like them I know I like okay I
think what's going to hurt them as
experience if they do make the playoffs
but again playing hard says something
right it says something they play hard
they play together I think it's going to
be a while and you know they needed that
veteran and I thought that veteran we're
going to be Andre Iguodala he didn't buy
into it but did you have any problem
with that Ridge where Iguodala not at
all because no one thought that this was
going to be like that the start of the
year and I thought it was going to be a
quick turnaround
when it happened they were gonna raid or
cut them right away and then they saw
how they played and he became a
bargaining chip so I think it was told
to him early when the transaction went
down hey we're gonna either cut you or
let you go so you can go son you know
with a contending team but once they saw
what they had and they started to play
well it kind of snowballed a little bit
so I had zero problem with him waiting
now and then getting a bargaining chip
out of it best movie you saw this year
did you see any of these oh yeah no well
you got little ones the little ones yeah
I can tell you the best of that frozen
wait did you go did you go to Patrick
Weitzel's party his Oscar party yeah
can you believe like my first when I
retired first five or six years we went
to that party because I would call into
your the white soul party doesn't start
till he's a big-time agent he's Patrick
Weitzel do big-time agent Holly yes yeah
yes endeavor agency yes
so his party starts at about 10 o'clock
and literally goes until I was on at
8:20 like the party goes on all night at
different places throughout the city and
there were fun parties they were they
were fun parties but father time catches
up to all of us Pete already said you
didn't you didn't go this year no no no
no no those days are way past now I
don't think they would probably even let
me in there like dude don't you you got
two kids go home Patrick would let you
in job course okay but who who do you
see there like the person where you go
I'm I can't even walk up to them like
did you ever have those moments
no not at all yeah
because I kind of knew them through
Patrick so I wasn't really I mean the
times I were going it was the height of
Matt and Ben you know the Good Will
Hunting days and all that so hanging
around with those guy who's been with
JLo back then yes I remember going to
been its route Lucy did been throat no
JLo through been a birthday party at one
of the top clubs at the time in the
mid-2000s and it was quite a scene
because that's when they were the height
of their relationship and not right you
were everywhere outside memory lane man
I know I'm sorry you're old now got
little ones you're in love you don't
leave the house you ride bikes did you
get that picture it was my first race
since obviously the passing of Coby and
Gigi and those seven others and it was
my first time on the bike actually
racing so I wanted to honor you know my
good friend Kobe so you know Castelli
who is my outfitter they sent me I
called it my mama angel outfit it was
all white my kit and my mama bear she
duct tape no number 24
duct tape 24 on the front in yellow and
number eight on the back in purple and a
number two on the sleeve and it was one
of the most difficult races and courses
here in Fontana that I've particularly
never done well in but I ended up
winning and I think it was a high
awesome
that's ensemble was looking after me so
I said Paulie the pitcher he'll share
that he'll share that so it was cool to
be on two wheels it was my little
tribute to mr. Kobe Bryant and his
daughter and those seven others who were
all lost too soon Reggie will be part of
TNT's all-star Saturday night broadcast
in Chicago as well as the old star game
festivities Sunday had 8:00 Eastern on
TNT safe travels there Aloysius and we
will talk to you next week don't think I
am NOT going to approach the
commissioner and the committee the Rules
Committee is about the veteran and I
like it I'm gonna I'm going to drop it
no I'm serious okay I am I am
legitimately curious about that that's
all
and if they want to put a media member
in and I can go Steven a you're right I
would but if you want to do that or once
again you want to get Drake we I can I
can revisit that that feud Thank You
Reggie for more Dan Patrick show tune in
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]